Mike asks is Jab Jab Jab right hook
coming out in audiobook form Mike I've
been dodging this question on Twitter
for months so congratulations for
penetrating episode 9 the answer is I
was supposed to do it in like December
of last year January I kind of like AG
you know the two full days in in the
kind of booth were just became
unpractical because vaynermedia is
exploding and so alright I've been
watching this guy I've been watching you
a time yeah this time this time I've got
your number
uh-huh we got him this time guys we got
him um so uh
ah so holder was like so edit any of
this went where was I recording booth no
prob yeah it was a practical baler
vaynermedia is exploding with characters
and and so I I just haven't gotten to it
and the truth is uh we're thinking about
having somebody else read it it's just
kind of one of these things that are
dragging now and is lending itself to me
not doing it which I know is now gonna
get a ton of booze in the comments
section and I apologize